you had no authority Mexico City  what were you doing that I was taking  some overdue holiday  so what's going on James they say you'll  finished order usually I think you're  just getting started magnificent isn't  she  zero to 60 in 3.2 seconds little tricks  up their sleeve  do one more thing for me what do you  have in mind  maybe disappear  tell me where he is he's everywhere you  should go there you're crossing over  Thai place over there is no mercy you're  protecting someone gotta wait for me why  should I trust you  because right now no best chance to stay  your life  this organisation do you know what it's  called it's name is Spectre jinx them or  me welcome James you came across me so  many times yes he never saw me what took  you so long  this really what you want living in the  shadows hunting being hunted always  alone  I don't stop to think about it  it was me James  the author of all your pain